سنستمر في مسار
خفض التصعيد والدبلوماسية ، ولكن
في الوقت نفسه ،
نحتفظ بالحق في الدفاع عن أنفسنا بشكل كامل
دفاعياً وهجومياً
في المنطقة
لأن هذا هو الالتزام الذي نتعهد
به كحكومة للحفاظ على مواطنينا.  لدينا
8 ملايين أو نحو ذلك من سكان
مختلف الدول الأعضاء البالغ عددها 192 في منظمة الأمم المتحدة
الآمنة
، وهذا هو التزامنا بالنموذج
الذي نقدمه للمنطقة ،
إنه نموذج آمن ، إنه نموذج آمن وهو نموذج
ترتكز على القيم العالمية التي
هي قيم ميثاق الأمم المتحدة
أه قدراتنا الدفاعية.
قدراتنا على اعتراض أه وصد
هذه الهجمات هي من
الطراز العالمي وهي
عالمية الآن وفي نفس الوقت يمكن
أن تكون هناك ترقيات هناك يمكن  دائمًا ما تكون
هناك تحسينات ، يمكن دائمًا أن يكون هناك
تعاون استخباراتي إضافي أه
وأعتقد أن هذه هي المجالات التي
نبحث عنها مع شركائنا في
الولايات المتحدة